more companies have started requiring  employees to be vaccinated against coven  19 and the new rule is even showing up  in job postings and it's not just small  businesses major corporations like  united airlines google and disney are  also on board  even for new employees indeed.com says  job posting requirements of requiring  vaccinations are up 90 percent in august  compared to july well that's less than  one percent of listings and indeed  economist says it's meaningful this may  potentially be the start of a trend that  really takes off  vaccine mandates for new applicants are  growing fastest in fields like software  development marketing education and  sales and it appears many workers are on  board a gallup poll finds 52 percent of  employees are in favor of vaccine  mandates 38 percent are against them and  10 percent say they're new